Adams with us in Detroit Michigan hey
Adam how are you I'm doing well how are
you better than I deserve
how can we know I'm in kind of a jumble
of the of the baby steps I got a lot of
money saved up I also have a lot of debt
and I don't know if I should be like
cashing in the savings to pay off the
debt
or just keep doing that I'm doing is I
think I'll be out of the student loan
hole in a year or two how much money is
in savings about $20,000 in my rainy day
which is about six months I've got
$1,000 in cash and I've got about
$100,000 in my 401k okay well as you
probably have heard we don't recommend
cashing out retirement accounts and how
much debt do you have not counting your
home about eighty five thousand dollars
in student loans and a $300 lease that's
up about ten months okay Chris yeah so
you use the rainy day terminology that
tells me that you know a little bit
maybe you know a little bit about our
Financial Peace University baby steps do
you yeah my wife was raised on it I
really come into contact with it within
the last couple of weeks now some kind
of just getting started with it okay
because it my next question was going to
be why did you go how to order because
they are sequential one two three four
so here's the deal baby step two is to
get out of non mortgage debt got a
consumer debt and you've got some money
that you've kind of gone forward with
your baby step three and having this
money in a trainee day emergency fund
and we want you to get rid of your can
non-mortgage consumer debt first so your
gut is right you want to get out of that
debt you just quit pay in that eight to
twelve to fourteen fifteen percent
interest on on a debt that you already
have the answer for some of it you have
the answer for twenty out of the eighty
something so that's what you want to do
you want to take that consumer debt keep
a thousand in there and attack that
consumer debt put them smallest to
largest attack the smallest one first
and pay the minimum payments on all the
rest and use that debt snowball until
you're completely out that working on
baby step three what's your household
income to about two hundred Oh awesome
awesome okay so if we throw twenty at
the eighty five
that leaves sixty five you're going to
do that
what 8 months yeah mainly expended
commission so it goes up and down but I
between 150 and 250 for last three years
okay but depending on when the
Commission comes with seasonal on it but
somewhere around the 8 month mark with
that kind of annual income you should be
knocking out that 65 and then
immediately rebuild and move on to baby
step 3 rebuild the emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses now if
your do you have if you have an
irregular income does your Commission
ever drop to zero you might have a 0
month it can but I have a really small
base salary some away from that I try to
budget off our base salaries almost all
the commissions gravy but so we don't
have to have this 20,000 or like buy
food is what I'm saying so you're good
then I agree with Chris completely I
would take the 20,000 and throw it at
that and the reason we do that is is
that it's for a very short period of
time this is not something that's going
you know it's going to take five years
for you to be sitting there with $1,000
in the bank and no emergency fund we're
talking about five to eight months here
how quickly you attack that and here's
what's interesting when I tell you to do
that it caught it takes your breath away
and it's like a blood of an emergency
but and that little bit of fear is going
to make you really focus and really
attack and you're going to really use
that in a positive way to get this debt
knocked out even faster because
everything we're doing around here is
about behavior modification
it's about causing you to believe and to
hope and to completely focus with
complete intensity and anything we can
do to manipulate that intentionally
ourselves and do it to ourselves to
cause us to automatically move as fast
as possible out of debt so that we have
control of our most powerful wealth
building tool which is our income
everything is about behavior management
the math on some of this stuff doesn't
work on the short term a long term it
works big time because you don't have
any payments then you're able to build
wealth hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
down
Oh